Japan… a country that brags about two things:
The first one is their used underwear vending
machines (really you can find on the streets!)
The second one is their immigration rate,
which is, by far, the lowest in the developed
world.
By comparison, in the United States, the foreign-born
population has risen to 14%.
Canada and New Zealand have 20% and 25% respectively.
While Japan has less than 2%.
So, what’s the reason for this?
Well, that’s their restrictive immigration
system.
This makes Japan something of a dream country
for politicians like Donald Trump or Marine
Le Pen.
If there is a word to define the current political
debate, that word would be “IMMIGRATION”.
In Europe, countries argue about what to do
with the refugees.
And it seems that politicians across the board
share the opinion that immigration is a problem
that needs to be stopped:
So then, Japan is the perfect example for
what it means to live in a country free of
immigrants.
And now you might wonder What does this mean
for their economy?
Do they really save money because they don’t
have to spend anything on social policies
for immigrants?
Do Japanesse workers enjoy a better standard
of living because they don’t have to compete
with foreign workforce?
Today on Visual Politik we will answer all
those questions.
But before, we are going to have a look at
the specifics of their immigration law.
ONE COUNTRY, ONE CULTURE, ONE RACE
This statement was said by the man who was
the Prime Minister of Japan in the mid-1980s,
YASUHIRO NAKASONE.
It clearly summarizes the immigration philosophy
of Japan.
Basically, there are just two ways of getting
into the Land of the Rising Sun: one is with
a work contract, the other is with a tourist
visa.
If a company wants to hire you overseas, you
will still need a visa.
And the only way you get a visa is by having
a university degree or having some specific
skills that are practically impossible to
find in the Japanese labor market.
So, if you are just a construction worker,
you’re never going to be able to get a work
permit…
That is unless you use this other program...
“Since Japan didn’t have a law to accept
workers from other Asian countries, like Vietnam
or the Philipinnes, they created the so-called
TECHNICAL INTERNAL TRAINING PROGRAM”.
This in summary is like becoming an Intern
in Japan… but getting half of the salary
that a Japanese intern would get.
Not only that, but with this “technical
internal training program”, your boss is
allowed to hold onto your passport and even
access to your bank account.
More worryingly, since they started this program,
thousands of Asian immigrants have just disappeared.
“When the Union representative spoke with
me, she said that my attitude was bad and
that If I continued to have this attitude…
if my actions continued, her friend would
hire a hitman to kill me”.
So what if you enter with a tourist visa?
Well, in that case, you can stay in the country
for a year and half as long as you can prove
you are studying Japanese.
Once that time has passed, you need to be
hired by a company.
And that can lead to a work visa.
But watch out!
Unlike other places like the US or the EU,
the Japanese working visa specifies your profession.
This means if you have a work visa for being
a chef, you cannot work as anything other
than a chef.
If you break this rule, your work permit will
not be renewed.
There is only one really effective way for
a foreigner to make a living in Japan:
“The easiest way to live here is by marrying
a japanese person”
Now you can understand how it is possible
that a country with over 127 million inhabitants
has just 2 million immigrants.
But what consequences does this have on the
daily life of of Japanese citizens?
WHO PAYS JAPANESE PENSIONS?
Japan is the oldest country in the world.
Not because of their long history but because
of the average age of their population.
In fact, estimations say that in 90 years,
they will lose over 44 million inhabitants
(about the entire population of Canada) because
of this.
This wouldn’t be a problem if it wasn’t
for the Social Security problem.
As you know, the pension system in most of
the countries works this way: the people who
are working today are the ones who pay the
pension of those who are retired.
As the workforce gets smaller and smaller,
year after year, there are less and less people
paying the pensions...
And more and more retired citizens needing
to draw social security.
And this is why things like this happen:
“Social security contributions cover only
60 per cent of these benefits.
The remaining 40 trillion yen comes from taxes
or, more precisely, public deficits”.
By the way, this beautiful sound you are listening
to is the music of MESCALINA, a rock and roll
band from Spain who sent us their music.
If you like it, check the links on the description
box below.
So even if the social security contributions
are increasing year after year, Japan cannot
pay their pensions effectively.
And this is why… and pay attention to this,
Japan has the highest public debt IN THE WORLD.
Their debt is more than double their GDP.
And their fiscal deficit (the difference between
their income and their spending) is higher
than the US one.
In other words… if Angela Merkel goes there,
she is gonna get really angry!
Mow you might be wondering: What does this
have to do with immigration?
The answer is, well, A LOT.
You see, we all have heard about how expensive
it is to integrate immigrants.
You have to pay social programs, integration
courses, etc… but no one talks about how
much it costs for a normal, native citizen.
For example, an American-born citizen costs
the government an average of $150,000 from
birth until he or she is 16 years old - and
this is only education and healthcare.
Depending on the state, you might add in other
spending.
All this money the government views as an
investment - money the government will get
back the day that citizen starts working and
paying taxes.
On the other hand, let’s take the example
of a Vietnamese immigrant to Japan.
He comes to the country when he is old enough
to start working.
His education and healthcare was already paid
for by the Vietnamese government.
In an average of two years, this immigrant
will find a job.
Of course, it might be a low-paid one, and,
therefore, he will pay little tax.
But the Japanese government didn’t have
to invest almost any money into him.
So, in other words, immigrants are free cash
for the government.
Since Japan has so few immigrants, they are
losing out on this influx of easy money.
This is why, in the middle of a fiscal crisis
in the year 2015, the Japanese Premier, Shinzo
Abe, made this announcement.
“Japan is under pressure to accept more
immigrants as the workforce shrinks”
But, despite what it looks like, this is not
Japan’s biggest problem: Japan has seen
20 years go past without any economic growth.
This is what experts have called the “lost
decade”.
And yes, immigration has a lot to do with
this as well.
THE COUNTRY THAT STOPPED INNOVATING
We all imagine Japan as the country of technology
and innovation.
The country where companies like Nintendo,
Sony, and Toshiba were all born.
Nonetheless, all these firms are very OLD!
Nintendo was founded in 1889.
Toyota was created in 1937.
Actually…
Can anybody name five Japanese companies created
in the 21st century?
I´m sure you couldn´t.
But, you could easily name 5 or 10 American
enterprises created in the last decade.
“Immigrant founders started 52 percent of
all new Silicon Valley companies between 1995
and 2005”
The entrepreneurial rate among the immigrant
populations is between two and three times
higher than natives.
And this is a trend you find in every country.
For instance, one of the founders of Google,
Sergey Brinn, was born in Moscow.
The co-founder of Whatsapp, Jan Coum, is Ukrainian.
But it’s not just about Silicon Valley start
ups.
Just have a walk in your neighbourhood and
you will see hundreds of Chinese stores, Mexican
restaurants, and all kinds of small businesses
created by immigrants
It makes complete sense that immigrants will
have an entrepreneurial spirit.
At the end of the day, those who leave their
country are natural risk takers.
Not only that, but immigrants brings another
culture with them which makes it easier for
them to think outside of the box.
Let’s look at an example: Charles Ferlmant
was a German immigrant who arrived to New
York City in the 19th century.
Soon he realized the workers in the city needed
some kind of food that could be easily cooked
and sold on the street.
That’s when he decided to import sausages
from his home country - this is how the HOT
DOG was born.
Today, this meal feeds millions of people
around the planet.
And this is just one example, there are thousands
of stories like this.
In short, when cultures mix, new ideas and
new methodologies are created.
This is what businesspeople call INNOVATION.
And this is the special sauce that makes companies
and countries grow.
So What´s going on in Japan?
Unsurprisingly, the have the lowest entrepreneurial
rate in the Industrialized world.
Just 7% of their population decides to start
a company.
By comparison, in Canada or New Zealand, this
percentage is 10%.
The Japanese dream is not to start a business,
but to get hired by one that already exists.
You know, those big companies like SONY or
TOSHIBA, those companies that have same corporate
structure and the same work culture that they
had in the eighties.
“Traditional Japanese electronics powerhouses
such as Sharp and Sony have incurred huge
losses and shed thousands of jobs, while competitors
Apple and Samsung have continued to increase
their market shares.”
Those who like football/soccer might keep
up with the UEFA and the World Cup.
Twenty years ago, there were at least two
Japanese companies sponsoring this events.
In 2016, the European Cup had zero Japanese
sponsors.
No matter where you look Japanese firms are
struggling to compete with European, American
and even Chinese companies.
And the reason is not a lack of money but
a lack of innovation.
This explains why Japan’s economy have been
frozen for two decades.
And of course, this has an impact on the daily
life of it’s citizens.
In order to keep a high level of productivity,
Japanese workers have the longest working
hours and the shortest vacations in all the
OECD countries.
And, meanwhile, they have the same salary
that their parents had.
So now we want to hear your opinion.
Do you think Japan should open their doors
to immigrants?
Or do you still think immigration is a problem
that needs to be stopped?
You can leave your response in the comments!
Soon we are going to be posting a video explaining
how Israel has become the world’s leading
innovation hub thanks to their immigrant population.
If you don´t want to miss that one hit that
subscribe button.
And if you like this video, give us a thumbs
up.
See you next time!